here's a weird and maybe this isn't true
but you
jim did train with the was it the navy
seals
is that made up nonsense i did not train
with the navy seals
but what uh what that might be referring
to is when i did the grinch i was uh
literally the makeup was like being
buried alive every day how long did it
take the first day was eight and a half
hours and i went back to my trailer and
put my leg through the wall and i told
ron howard i couldn't do the movie
and uh then brian grazer came in and uh
being the fix-it man and uh came up with
a brilliant idea which was to hire a
gentleman who is trained to uh
to teach cia operatives uh how to endure
torture
and so
that's how i got through the grinch
i would like a good gift it was quite
hilarious you said eat everything you
see
and uh if you're freaking out and you
start to spiral downward uh turn the
television on change your pattern have
someone you know come up and smack you
in the head um you know punch yourself
in the leg so
or or smoke smoke as much as you
possibly can so i was this grinch
give me a light
and this giant cigarette holder so so
the yak hair wouldn't go on fire
the green yeah the green yak hair that
turned inward and went crack
it was horrifying it was horrifying it
was just like it's for the kids it's for
the kids
how many months was that uh that i did
the makeup 100 times
good noise
you know what got me through it the bee
gees
i was in a scene where i was in bed
listening to the radio because the voice
of the man reading the shipping forecast
really turned me on
this is the work i do